bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant en direct de l'hémicycle
la séance de questions cribles alors les
questions que vous le savez ce sont ces
questions très précises que les
sénateurs posa un ministre le thème
aujourd'hui c'est la laïcité dans le
milieu professionnel et les ministres
présents se sont donc michel sapin
ministre du travail et anne marie
escoffier ministre déléguée à la
décentralisation on se retrouve tout de
suite après la tentation de la rue
prolonger l'espace d'état plutôt que de
prendre loger l'espace privé
je rejoindrai donc les définitions du
conseil d'état et du conseil
constitutionnel et vous êtes roger
monsieur de nice où madame le ministre
sur le point soulevé par monsieur
portier au travers de l'actualité
concernant la sphère baby loup les juges
du fond ont résisté à un arrêt rendu par
la cour de cassation aussi celle ci
devra siéger en assemblée plénière un
arrêt fondamentale est attendue sur ce
point les échos consacrer ces derniers
jours un article à la société paprec qui
vient d'appliquer à une entreprise
privée
les concept de laïcité auquel l'état est
soumis aussi je vous demande si le
gouvernement entend présenter un projet
de loi pourrait affirmer le système
consacré par nos juridictions s'agirait
d'un signal fort ou s'il souhaite
modifier ce système pour que la rue
l'entreprise privée prolonge l'espace
d'état je vous remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur michel
sapin ministre du travail de l'emploi de
la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur marseille vous avez
rappelé un certain nombre des grands
principes de la laïcité et la séparation
qui existe entre l'espace privé et
l'espace public
il y à des endroits qui sont en quelque
sorte au croisement des deux espaces
vous parliez de la rue ou de
l'entreprise et la question est alors de
savoir comment on équilibre ces
principes dans ces espaces qui sont en
quelque sorte des espaces mixtes
ça n'est pas vrai de tous les espaces de
travail et comme vous le savez il est
des espaces de travail qui sont des
services publics et qui dès lors son
100% dans l'espace public et où les
principes de laïcité au sens où nous les
entendons ici
applique évidemment dans toutes leurs
forces et aussi dans toute leur
puissance
aucun signe distinctif dans l'espace
public service public ne peut faire
différence entre les uns et les autres
s'agissant de l'entreprise puisqu'au
fond baby loup et être en situation
d'entreprise des espaces privés de
l'entreprise mais au contact avec du
public
la question est de savoir s'il était
possible d'interdire catégoriquement
pour tous les personnels le port de
signes distinctifs ou si comme
l'autorisé le code du travail
il était possible de le faire pour
certaines catégories par exemple celles
qui étaient au contact avec le public
j'ai décrit là le sujet qui est le sujet
juridiquement aujourd'hui portés devant
les tribunaux avec sept allers retours
que vous avez décrit de mémoire un
conseil des prud'hommes qui a considéré
que le licenciement pour port d'un signe
distinctif était légitime
une cour d'appel qui avait confirmé ce
jugement de premier instance la cour de
cassation qui a infirmé en considérant
que le règlement intérieur intérieur
lui-même était trop catégorique est trop
général puis une nouvelle cour d'appel
celle de paris qui sait dans le jargon
rebeller en reprenant la position
première la cour de cassation devra et
je lui laisse bien entendu l'entière
liberté aboutir à une décision finale
mais nous aurons à ce moment là en tirer
les conclusions ma conviction c'est
qu'il existe aujourd'hui au sein du code
du travail et dans les entreprises des
outils qui permettent de faire la
différence qui permettent de réglementer
sont pourtant interdire de manière
catégorique et c'est plutôt dans ce sens
là me semble-t-il que devrait aller le
sens de l'histoire
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
marseille merci monsieur le ministre
pour cette réponse effectivement nous
allons attendre avec impatience cette
décision qui fera date
sans nul doute parce que c'est un sujet
à l'évidence que beaucoup d'entreprises
vont
examinez parce qu'elles vont connaître
ces difficultés là je crois que c'est
important que nos principes fondamentaux
soient réaffirmés peut-être faudra-t-il
malgré tout réaffirmé un certain nombre
de points pour compléter les textes
parce qu'à l'évidence le temps passe et
parfois nos textes
compte tenu de la réalité des choses
méritent d'être adapté et je dirais que
c'est aussi un petit peu malheureusement
un échec de notre système éducatif parce
que l'esprit de tolérance qui devrait
être enseignée davantage dans les
familles et dans l'école
le trouve là malheureusement ses limites
et c'est la loi c'est les juridictions
qui sont amenés j'allais dire par delà
les familles par delà le système
éducatif à faire en sorte que cet esprit
de tolérance puisse continuer à vivre
dans notre pays
merci la parole est à monsieur claude
domeizel pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
madame monsieur le ministre en 2011 et
plus précisément en deux étapes le 28
avril et le 31 mai pour des raisons de
contraintes d'agenda et d'organisation
des débats le sénat a voté une
résolution tendant à demander que soit
organisée le 9 décembre de chaque année
une journée de la laïcité
les débats ont été riches serein et
cette sérénité est à l'image de ce qui
caractérise la laïcité
permettez moi de citer une phrase qui me
plaît beaucoup
concernant la laïcité la laïcité c'est
comme l'air qu'on respire sans s'en
apercevoir
c'est vrai et on pourrait préciser
pourrait penser que sa banalité
dispense d'en parler et pourtant la
qualité nous incite à rappeler de temps
en temps tu que la france est une
république indivisible laïque
démocratique et sociale
c'est pourquoi le groupe socialiste a à
mon initiative proposer le vote d'une
résolution demandant que la république
française
un score une journée nationale de la
laïcité le 9 décembre de chaque année
garante de la cohésion républicaine
journée non fériés et non sommet a
précisé et permettant chaque année de
faire le point d'abord sur les
différentes actions menées en la matière
à part les pouvoirs publics
et deuxièmement d'être l'occasion de
manifestations au sein du système
associatif et éducatif
dois-je préciser que cette proposition
de résolution avait été également
déposée par une de nos collègues du
groupe ump sophie joissains à peu près
dans les mêmes termes
et c'est d'ailleurs l'occasion pour moi
de souhaiter que notre collègue madame
joissains retrouve totalement sa santé
puisqu'elle est retenu par pour des
raisons de santé à la suite d'un
accident chez elle alors vous savez il
ne s'agit pas de raviver les polémiques
bien au contraire c'est un rappel de la
tolérance et du vivre ensemble
alors madame la ministre quelles
réponses à donner ou donnera à cette
résolution qui a été largement très
largement voté ici au sénat je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à madame anne marie
escoffier mêlée chargé de la
décentralisation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur nommé l monsieur
valls aurait aimé répondre à votre
question s'il n'avait pas été retenu
dans une réunion avec ses homologues
belges et néerlandais à l'heure
kylie voilà donc il m'a chargé de vous
apporter la réponse à une question qui
est au coeur des problématiques le
gouvernement suit à 2 façon tout à fait
favorable je reprend d'ailleurs la belle
définition que vous avez donnée et à
laquelle le gouvernement donne plein
d'accord comme l'air que l'on respire
sans s'en apercevoir
j'ai bien entendu votre votre voeu de
cette résolution qui a été examiné à
deux reprises le 28 avril le 31 mai
dernier et qui est corrélé de 2011
pardon 2011 oui j'ai bien entendu
pardonnez-moi est corrélé par un avis du
19 novembre 2013
je ne me trompe pas donné par
l'observatoire de la laïcité est présidé
par jean louis bianco qui avait émis une
recommandation allant dans les mêmes
allant dans le même sens sur la base des
mêmes principes le gouvernement
au delà de l'ensemble des pouvoirs
publics qui sont à l'oeuvre pour engager
des actions de promotion de la laïcité
entend bien effectivement aller dans ce
sens et veiller à ce que tous les moyens
soient mis en oeuvre pour faire
comprendre ce qu'il ya derrière le mot
laïcité qui est plutôt la coexistence
entre une séparation des églises et de
l'état une liberté totale d'exercice du
culte tout cela ce sont des notions qui
sont bien retenu au plan territorial
chaque administration a vocation à
relayer cette politique par
l'intermédiaire des correspondants
laïcité qui ont été désignés dans chaque
préfecture et à débat de ses questions
au sein des conférences départementales
de la laïcité le 9 décembre c'est la
date anniversaire de la loi du 9
décembre 1905 la vie dit est une belle
occasion pour faire un bilan de ses
actions de promotion mais cette journée
ne doit en aucun cas faire oublier que
la laïcité c'est une action permanente
et de terrain une action de chaque jour
c'est quelque chose de très concret
qu'il faut faire vivre véritablement au
quotidien merci madame la ministre
monsieur de moselle merci madame le
ministre pour votre réponse qui
réponse tout à fait dans l'esprit qui
avait été celui de la résolution et
j'espère que le 9 décembre prochain nous
aurons une manifestation nationale n'ont
pas départementale mais au niveau
national pour que ont marqué cette
journée du 9 décembre qui est comme vous
l'avez rappelé l'anniversaire de la
séparation des églises et de l'état je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à mme adam
eliane assassi pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen si monsieur le
président madame ou monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues composante majeure
du pacte républicain la laïcité exige de
la rigueur intellectuelle
à l'heure où elle est largement des
voiliers notamment par l'extrême droite
qui a fait de sa conception de la
laïcité un outil pour stigmatiser et
alimenter les communautarismes alors le
lit le si le législateur se doit de
participer à ce travail rigoureux
intellectuelle doit-il pour autant
encore légiféré
la question est cruciale car dans ce
domaine le recours à la loi peut
conduire à réglementer sans fin ou
encore à déplacer le problème
aussi pour ne pas risquer de toucher à
l'équilibré un corpus législatif déjà
conséquent nous devons bien me
semble-t-il distinguer ce qui doit
relever de la loi du débat politique
voire du débat philosophique c'est suite
à la publication en mars 2013 de deux
arrêts de la cour de cassation que des
voix se sont élevées pour demander au
législateur de légiférer parmi ces voix
celle du défenseur des droits qui a
demandé une clarification de la loi sur
la laïcité
estimant que le parcours judiciaire de
la fête de la sphère dit baby loup
illustre des difficultés
d'interprétation des textes en sens
inverse
la commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme a adopté un avis sur
la laïcité le 2 octobre 2013 invitant à
ne pas renforcer un arsenal législatif
déjà riche mais a lutté avant tout
contre toute ignorance laïque
clarification de la loi par le débat
pourquoi pas mais je le répète doit-on
légiférer le droit est clair
l'obligation de neutralité ne peut
s'imposer que si l'activité est prise en
charge par la personne privée est une
activité de service public
la neutralité ne doit s'imposer qu'aux
personnes publiques ou privées exerçant
une mission de service public
si des difficultés apparaissent
aujourd'hui dans certaines entreprises
de droit privé c'est parce que les
frontières entre services publics et
privés deviennent floues en effet d'une
part la puissance publique des legs de
plus en plus sa gestion et
l'exploitation des activités relevant du
service public à des personnes privées
et d'autre part il y à aussi défaillance
de l'état en matière de développement et
modernisation de service public alors je
répète doit-on clarifier ou redéfinir
les critères permettant de déterminer ce
qui relève du service et ou de l'intérêt
général
je pense que ce qu'il y à beaucoup de
questions sur le sujet mais je pense
aussi qu'elle ne trouveront pas de
réponse simplement au détour d'une
séance de questions au crible nous avons
besoin me semble-t-il d'un débat
approfondi et rigoureux pour le coup
bien sûr de gagner loigné me semble-t-il
enfants tout cas c'est ce que je
souhaiterais bien éloignées des
stéréotypes ou des raccourcis qui sont
souvent stigmatisant merci monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la présidente à ça si vous avez
contribué au débat plus que vous n'avez
souhaité y répondre
sur un sujet qui évidemment est délicat
et pour lesquels il faut manier les
choses avec beaucoup de subtilité je le
voudrais juste rappeler sont ils une
phrase de briand alors pas ici c'était à
l'assemblée nationale car il était
député au moment du débat de 1905 il
était un fervent défenseur de cette loi
de 1905 et qui disait je crois de
mémoire il faut dans un débat comme
celui ci avoir du sang-froid et résister
à la surenchère
car la laïcité c'est le sang froid la
laïcité c'est l'apaisement
il faut trouver des solutions mais
qu'ils soient des solutions d'apaisement
et non pas des eaux peut dessiner une
solution qui opposerait vous avez
parfaitement décrit aujourd'hui l'état
de la question juridique
j'attendrai donc sur baby loup en
particulier que la cour de cassation
pour la dernière fois après un
aller-retour entre deux cours d'appel
puisse dire à son avis le droit
aujourd'hui et c'est au vu de ce droit
que nous verrons s'il est besoin de le
faire évoluer dans les textes pour ma
part je rappelle à chaque fois les
termes du code du travail les termes du
code du travail qui je le cite dit les
restrictions à la liberté religieuse
donc les restrictions peuvent exister
dans le cadre d'une entreprise privée
indépendamment bien entendu du service
public qui lui découvert par le principe
de neutralité
les restrictions à la liberté religieuse
doivent être justifiées par la nature de
la tâche à accomplir par répondre à une
exigence professionnelle essentielle et
déterminante et doit être proportionnée
au but recherché il est donc aujourd'hui
possible d'interdire dans l'entreprise
le port de signes distinctifs par
exemple s'il met en cause la sécurité
par rapport à la proximité d'une machine
ou si le poste en question est un
contact avec de très jeunes enfants ou
des gens influençable auquel cas il est
possible sur un point précis d'interdire
ce port là sans pour autant se mettre
dans une situation contraire à la loi
donc je pense qu'il ya aussi un enjeu de
connaissance de la loi et des modalités
de mise en oeuvre de la loi qui peuvent
permettre peut-être de répondre aux à la
très juste problématique que vous avez
posé dans votre question
merci madame présidente assassi merci
monsieur le président sur merci à
monsieur ministre parce que votre
réponse me satisfait pour une bonne
partie parce que c'est vrai que le sujet
est un beau sujet la laïcité mes idées
de tombeaux que
aujourd'hui la laïcité the lady est en
difficulté et notamment par des forces
extrêmes mais elle est aussi en
difficulté parce qu'il me semble que
celles et ceux qui sont attachés sont
peu mobilisés pour réaffirmer
aujourd'hui qu'elle est une composante
majeure comme je les dis de notre pacte
républicain c'est pourquoi il me
semblerait que notre haute assemblée
pourrait se voir confier une mission
pour justement avec la rigueur qui qui
est la sienne et que l'on reconnaît
évoqué la laïcité dans tout dans toutes
les actions qui peuvent permettre
l'affirmation de la citoyenneté je pense
que par les temps qui courent ce serait
une belle chose
merci la parole est à madame esther
benbassa pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2004
2005 jean baubérot spécialiste de la
laïcité rédiger une déclaration
universelle sur la laïcité au 21ème
siècle qui est lancée trois principes
fondamentaux la liberté de conscience
comme libertés publiques
l'autonomie de l'état et des
institutions publiques à l'égard de
toute religion et conviction et
l'égalité dans l'exercice des droits
il définissait la laïcité comme
l'harmonisation de ses trois principes
après avoir raconté la séparation des
églises et de l'état d'une manière
uniquement conflictuelle heckly jean
baubérot le discours social dominant
effectué un virage à 180 degrés lors du
centenaire de la loi en 2005 on insiste
maintenant sur saône irénisme fin de
citation de la promulgation d'une loi
visant soustraire l'état toute ingérence
du pouvoir des églises et à permettre un
vivre ensemble respectueux de la
religion de l'autre on est passé au
culte d'un concept susceptible de régler
tous les problèmes de la république est
de rassembler tous les déçus de sa
vallée de ses valeurs une forme
d'intégrisme et je mets intégrisme
guimet laïque s'est trouvée ainsi
relayés par une certaine vulgate
républicaine qui cherche enfermer la
france dans un schéma
binaire avec d'un côté ses partisans
érigé en bon français et les autres au
premier plan les musulmans stigmatisés
comme a priori à l'etivaz cette nouvelle
religion qu'est devenue la laïcité pour
d'aucuns la machine à exclure est en
marche
or la laïcité ce devrait être
l'inclusion au delà de la neutralité
impérative des services publics
on est venu à exiger cette neutralité
dans l'espace public lui-même voile pour
certaines missions de service public
pourtant assuré par le privé ou
simplement des nounous de nos enfants ma
question monsieur le ministre est la
suivante
serait-il vraiment sage que l'état
n'arrive à dicter les principes d'une
laïcité à abstraite à l'entreprise
privée elle même quand ces dernières
semblent parfois gérer beaucoup mieux la
question religieuse et ce sans fracas ni
vaines polémiques
merci merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice merci pour cette question je
répondrais principalement à la fin de
votre question mais je serai peut-être
d'accord avec vous pour dire qu' il ne
peut pas y avoir de culte de la laïcité
je pense même que ce sont des mots qui
sont antinomiques et il ne peut pas
d'oxygène vous avez raison monsieur le
sénateur spécialiste de ces questions
étaient mode mais un général un bts mai
mais gt gt gt je pense qu'il faut il
faut parfois parlé avec le sourire d'un
sujet extrêmement sérieux qui est celui
qui est celui de la laïcité
de même que je ne peux pas comprendre
qu'il puisse y avoir laïcité et
intégrisme l'intégrisme dans la laïcité
ce deux mots qui s'oppose totalement est
intégralement donc la laïcité c'est
l'apaisement
la laïcité c'est le respect de l'autre
et c'est le respect de l'autre dans la
vie publique avec l'impératif de la
neutralité du fonctionnement de cette
vie publique
mais c'est le respect de l'autre aussi
dans la sphère privée vous ne peut
varier de l'entreprise privée je crois
avoir déjà répondu
un salon de la semaine au code du
travail prévoit la possibilité de
restreindre la liberté religieuse ou
l'affichage de son sentiment religieux
de sa croyance religieuse en fonction de
raison qu'ils sont suffisamment ciblé ça
doit être générale pas être catégorique
mais c'est possible je voudrais insister
sur le fait que comme cela a été cité je
crois par vous même monsieur marseille
des avis ont déjà été rendus et je
voudrais en particulier assisté sur eux
à code un code de bonne conduite le
guide de la gestion du fait religieux
dans notre entreprise privée qui a été
édictée à l'automne dernier par
l'observatoire de la laïcité
l'observatoire de la laïcité et qui a
fait un excellent guide qui est un
excellent document d'information pour
permettre aux entreprises chef
d'entreprise ou ressources humaines à
ceux qui sont chargés de la gestion du
personnel des conflits qui peuvent
exister de s'inspirer d'un certain
nombre de bonnes pratiques
parce que oui dans l'entreprise privée à
beaucoup d'endroits ces problèmes-là ont
trouvé une solution respectueuse de
chacun
comme toujours on voit les cas qui font
problème qui font des barques je pense à
baby loup et c'est un vrai débat
mais beaucoup d'autres entreprises ont
résolu ce problème par le débat par la
discussion et par le dialogue
c'est ce à quoi je citerai chacun merci
monsieur madame même un saint merci
monsieur le ministre je comme vous le
voyez vous le savez d'après ce que j'ai
lu que je suis pour une laïcité
harmonieuse et pas une laïcité
qui friserait une certaine religiosité
dans son application
c'est vrai que l'entrée lui le texte
dont vous avez parlé puisque je m'en
suis inspiré inspiré néanmoins il serait
aussi opportun de prendre en
considération que que la laïcité peut
être gérée dans l'entreprise privée mon
souhait serait monsieur le ministre que
les discriminations aussi soient gérées
avec autant d'habileté dans le privé
d'ailleurs j'avais fait une loi à une
proposition de loi avec laquelle vous
n'étiez pas d'accord sur l'action de
groupe en matière de discrimination
il serait temps qu'on réfléchisse
également au problème de la
discrimination dans l'entreprise merci
beaucoup merci la parole est à madame
françoise laborde pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le président merci ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation mais je suis ravi de voir
que madame la ministre anne marie
escoffier ne répondra au cours de sa
première année de travail l'observatoire
de la laïcité au sein duquel j'ai
l'honneur de représenter le sénat aux
côtés de notre collègue rené garrec a
lancé plusieurs chantiers qu'il s'agisse
de son application dans les
collectivités où du fait religieux dans
l'entreprise mais j'ai préféré revenir
sur le premier lieu où se vit cette
valeur chère aux radicaux l'école de la
république
l'observatoire a participé à la
rédaction de la charte de la laïcité à
l'école
composée de 15 articles cette charte n'a
pas pour unique vocation d'être affichée
dans chaque établissement
elle doit servir de supports éducatifs
afin de transmettre aux élèves une
laïcité qui rassemble autour des valeurs
de notre république
en tenant à l'écart de l'école publique
toute forme de communautarisme et de
prosélytisme pour ce faire un outil
pédagogique a été mis à la disposition
des cent des enseignants ainsi que afin
que la charte soit comprise par les
élèves
aujourd'hui près de six mois après son
dévoilement
il serait utile de connaître le premier
bilan de l'application de la charte au
sein des établissements scolaires
cette initiative ne serait être
appréhendé sans prendre en compte
l'introduction d'un enseignement laïque
de la morale prévue à partir de la
rentrée de septembre 2015
cet ensemble constitue la pierre
angulaire de la refondation de l'école
que les radicaux ont soutenu avec force
et conviction la formation à
l'enseignement de la morale laïque
auprès du personnel éducatif est
primordial pouvez vous madame la
ministre nous informer du niveau de
préparation des enseignants en vue de
l'instauration de l'enseignement civique
et morale
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice françoise laborde
je suis sûr que vincent peillon aurait
été heureux parce que vous connaissez
ses convictions en matière de laïcité et
lorsqu'il a demandé à ce que la charte
de la laïcité soit affiché dans tous les
établissements scolaires c'était un
véritable une véritable volonté
une détermination qui a d'ailleurs été
partagé avec l'observatoire dont vous
avez rappelé que vous en faisiez que
vous en faisiez partie
je voudrais reprendre certains des maux
qui sont ceux du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui entend bien que soit
dispensé un ensemble de connaissances et
de réflexion sur les valeurs les
principes les règles qui permettent dans
la république de vivre ensemble c'est le
socle de ses valeurs qui en fait fonde
notre république comme vous l'avez dit
c'est aussi pour les pour nos
établissements scolaires et pour nos
élèves la capacité à former le sujet
moral à acquérir un jugement et il
s'agit d'aider aujourd'hui les enfants à
réfléchir aussi en terme de programme
d'abord le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a à fixer un calendrier de
remise des travaux du conseil supérieur
de programme qui a été
instituée vous le savez par la loi de
refondation de l'école du 8 juillet 2013
dans selon ce calendrier de remise des
travaux le ministre a demandé qu'une
nouvelle définition du socle commun des
connaissances des compétences et de la
culture et des programmes d'enseignement
moral et civique soit fixée et le les
travaux doivent être remis dès ce
printemps 2014 donc très vite vous en
aurez connaissances en matière de
formation puisque vous interrogiez le
ministre sur la formation des maîtres
aujourd'hui le code de l'éducation
nationale a été complété par cette même
loi du 8 juillet 2013 qui précise que le
service public de l'éducation fait
acquérir à tous les élèves le respect de
l'égalé dignité des êtres humains de la
liberté de conscience et de la laïcité
par son organisation et ses méthodes
comme par la formation des maîtres qui
enseigne il favorise la coopération
entre les élèves
il ya donc là tout un plan de formation
continue qui est en cours et qui doit
d'ailleurs se mettre en place maintenant
très très rapidement et dans le cadre de
la formation initiale ce que vous
vouliez savoir des actions de formation
sont conduites par les écoles
supérieures du professorat de
l'éducation est soutenue par les
services aussi bien de l'enseignement
supérieur que de l'enseignement scolaire
merci mme en deux merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je vous
remercie donc pour votre réponse
j'ai envie aussi de rebondir sur ce qu'a
dit tout à l'heure mon collègue dos mais
elle parce que je pense qu'il faut
profiter aussi de la journée du 9
décembre pour que d'endives tous les
établissements scolaires on puisse avoir
des débats des échanges entre élèves et
professeurs ou intervenants extérieurs
j'ai aussi envie de vous dire que je
suis content d'entendre vos propos sur
la formation initiale mais j'ai eu
l'opportunité de participer à une
journée de formation continue sur la
laïcité proposait donc par les services
de l'inspection académique à laquelle
j'appartiens et le succès rencontré par
cette journée
a été à la hauteur de la fréquentation
est révélateur de l'intérêt des
personnels de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi de leurs besoins je vous remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur roger
karoutchi pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire c'est le président
madame monsieur le ministre
la laïcité c'est un bien beau principe
mais contrairement à ce qu'on dit est ce
que j'ai entendu je ne crois pas que ce
soit l'air qu'on respire bien des états
démocratiques ne sont pas des états
laïcs
bien des états autour de nous en europe
ou dans le monde anglo saxon sont des
états extrêmement libre extrêmement
démocratique et n'ont rien de l'oeil
par conséquent c'est quelque part une
spécificité pas uniquement une
spécificité française
alors ma seule question elle serait de
dire au gouvernement au delà des
questions sphère publique sphère privée
quelle est votre conception de la
laïcité
je ne crois pas que la laïcité soit
seulement je les dis l'air qu'on respire
je pense qu'elle est définie or à leurs
jours à jour en fonction des évolutions
politiques publiques privées on assiste
depuis quelques années à une résurgence
des religions des forces religieuses
ça veut pas dire qu'elles sont contre la
laïcité ça veut dire que l'état doit
avoir une réflexion sur l'évolution la
laïcité quelle laïcité voulons-nous
laïcité du début du 20e siècle
combative à l'égard des religions qui à
l'époque tu métro l'état ou bien une
laïcité serait même une laïcité positive
une laïcité qui consiste à dire l'état
c'est autre chose
il y a les religions ils y allaient
moral ils y allaient philosophie et il y
à l'état et l'état c'est autre chose
c'est au dessus de tout ça et je crois
qu'il y a un vrai débat dans ce que l'on
dit que ce soit dans l'école que ce soit
dans l'entreprise est ce que je voudrais
comprendre c'est vraiment quelle est la
vision
s'il ya une vision globale du
gouvernement sur cette question de
laïcité
j'ai regardé j'ai lu l'ouvragé de
monsieur peillon de 2010 sur ferdinand
buisson excellent président du conseil
de la troisième république
mais où il dit la laïcité c'est une
religion d'état pardon de vous dire
c'est pas ma conviction une région des
tâches sais pas ce que ça veut dire
et donc en la matière quelle est la
vision non pas de vous-mêmes
personnellement mais quelle est la
vision du gouvernement sur la laïcité
merci monsieur le ministre en deux
minutes sur un débat qui anime notre
pays depuis un siècle et demi
l'art et l'art est difficile même si
vous avez commencé en posant les
questions et pas en répondant à ces
questions il vous répond serait aussi
intéressante monsieur le sénateur
karoutchi dois-je essayé à partir de là
de donner quelques éléments de réponse
je ne sais pas si c'est l'air que l'on
respire mais c'est en tous les cas l'air
que l'on respire sur notre territoire
quand cette expression est utilisée cela
veut dire qu'au fond la laïcité est
consubstantielle à notre manière à nous
de concevoir le vivre ensemble dans
d'autres pays il peut y avoir d'autres
éléments qui sont le coeur du vivre
ensemble
chez nous c'est le coeur du vivre
ensemble et la laïcité
cela a été dit rappelé par les uns et
par les autres par rapport à la religion
ce n'est pas qu'une question par rapport
à la religion ou une religion mais on
voit bien que ce sujet est aujourd'hui
extrêmement présents comme il a été
extrêmement présents au début de
l'affirmation républicaine de la laïcité
la laïcité ce n'est pas la négation des
religions
c'est la reconnaissance de tout c'est le
respect de tout il y en a pas une qui
s'impose aux autres c'est le respect de
toutes les religions il n'y a pas de
hiérarchie entre les religions y aurait
pas la bonne religion qui devraient être
respectées par la laïcité et celles qui
ne devrait pas être respectés c'est il
n'y a pas de hiérarchie
il n'y a pas de discrimination entre les
religions le respect doit être le même à
condition évidemment que l'exercice de
ces religions se fasse dans des
conditions compatibles avec les
principes de la république et les
principes de la laïcité
voilà me semble-t-il en quelques mots
sur des débats extrêmement lourd
difficile
subtil l'esprit dans lequel nous nous
plaçons y compris
lorsqu'il s'agit de savoir s'il faut
légiférer ou pas légiférer et à ce stade
là je pense que ce qui a été utilisé
comme méthode
l'observatoire de la laïcité qui a
conclu qu'il n'était pas nécessaire à ce
stade nous verrons ce que dira la cour
de cassation de légiférer mais qui a
pensé qu'il fallait qui est un guide une
manière d'aider chacun à aborder ces
difficultés parce qu'au fond c'est assez
simple ici de dire quels sont les
principes c'est parfois beaucoup plus
compliqué lorsqu'on est au contact
quand on est dans la réalité elle même
dans un service public comme dans une
entreprise dont aider chacun à surmonter
ses difficultés en s'inspirant des
grands principes qui me semble-t-il
peuvent nous réunir voilà l'esprit dans
lequel le gouvernement travaille merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur karoutchi
a très brièvement à monsieur le
président moi je pense qu'effectivement
le respect des convictions de chacun
c'est la base
parce que sinon c'est plus possible et
l'état et la république est là pour
permettre à chacun d'avoir ses
convictions sa pratique tant qu'elle
respecte
naturellement les règles et les lois de
la république et puis je vais vous faire
une proposition non pas de journée de la
laïcité je suis pas convaincu qu'il
faille x dont 1 les journées sur tous
les thèmes mais le parlement est quand
même un lieu où après tout parlé de
république et laïcité ce serait pas non
plus absurde
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer un
jour un grand débat sur la république et
la laïcité à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat
on ne rompt donnerait à nos concitoyens
l'image d'un parlement qui regarde
comment ils vivent ce qu'ils vivent et
comment on peut faire pour le vivre
ensemble
merci la parole est à madame delphine
bataille pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
madame et monsieur le ministre après
plusieurs siècles en france de luttes
religieuses et idéologiques la laïcité
est devenu une valeur fondatrice de
notre identité républicaine
selon jean jaurès démocratie et laïcité
sont deux termes identiques clé de voûte
de l'édifice républicain la laïcité qui
garantit la liberté et l'égalité de tous
les citoyens restent aujourd'hui au
coeur du débat de société et son
affirmation est plus que jamais
fondamentale la laïcité est en effet
menacée d'un côté par les replis
identitaire et communautaire favorisée
par un contexte de crise économique et
sociale
et de l'autre par l'extrême droite et
les mouvements populistes qui l'a
manipulé l'instrumentalise par ailleurs
la puissance publique réforme après
réforme a provoqué des dérives du
principe de laïcité qui fait
actuellement l'objet d'une rue d'une
surexposition et d'un traitement souvent
partiales des médias sous le quinquennat
précédent les plus hautes autorités
n'avaient pas hésité à remettre en
question la neutralité de l'état et le
consensus républicain autour de la
laïcité
certains groupes minoritaires se sont
aujourd'hui autorisés à s'en prendre à
l'école de la république
d'autres s'attaquent à la neutralité
religieuse de la république jusque dans
l'entreprise
l'affichage d'une charte de la laïcité
dans les écoles ainsi que l'installation
de l'observatoire de la laïcité ça a été
rappelée constituent de bonnes réponses
à cette idéologie de l'obscurantisme
néanmoins la laïcité est bafouée au
quotidien prières adressées par des
sportifs dans des stades programmation
de metz dans le calendrier des
cérémonies de commémoration nationale
portent de plus en plus fréquents du
voile dans des espaces publics
octroi de subventions par des
collectivités à des associations
développant une idéologie religieuse
parité des financements publics entre
école publique et école privée et c'est
dans ce contexte madame la ministre le
gouvernement proposera t-il de fixer un
cadre législatif précis respectant le
principe de laïcité en développant
l'information et la formation sur les
règles de droit et la gestion des
situations concrètes relevant du fait
religieux je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre merci mêmes
parents monsieur le président merci
madame la sénatrice de jeu je réponds
mais évidemment madame la ministre
aurait pu le faire à ma place sur des
sujets comme ceux ci qui nous réunit ce
qu'ils font vraiment le coeur de notre
conviction
la laïcité ce sont à la fois des
principes nous en avons parlé rapidement
mais au fond on peut se retrouver autour
de ces principes
et c'est ensuite la mise en oeuvre de
ces principes et c'est souvent la
question de la mise en oeuvre elle même
qui est la plus la plus délicate parce
que la laïcité n'a pas besoin de
l'adjectif
a pas besoin d'être tolérante
harmonieuse elle est laïcité mais l'été
un équilibre elle est un équilibre
délicat entre ce qui est la sphère
publique principe de neutralité et le
respect des convictions individuelles de
chacun y compris des convictions
religieuses
doué je retiens cet aspect là de votre
question c'est pour ça j'y réponds la
nécessité d'informer d'informer à la
fois sur les principes mêmes mais aussi
d'informer sur la manière de surmonter
les difficultés
quand une difficulté dans cet équilibre
au sein de la laïcité peut apparaître
c'est vrai évidemment dans l'école d'où
la nécessité d'une information à la fois
des jeunes mais aussi des professeurs
des équipes pour régler les difficultés
quand ces difficultés peuvent apparaître
c'est vrai aussi dans l'entreprise et je
veux redire ici l'importance que le
gouvernement accorde à la fois à
l'observatoire de la laïcité auquel vous
avez fait vous aussi allusion que vous
avez nommés et à ce guide
ce guide de la laïcité dans l'entreprise
que vous savez bien madame la sénatrice
si vous faites partie de l'observatoire
de la laïcité que cet observatoire a
édité et qui est un très bon document un
excellent document qui redit les
principes mais qui redit aussi la
manière de surmonter les difficultés
dans l'entreprise
oui dans une entreprise on peut porter
sur soi un signe distinctif
c'est le principe mais pas dans
n'importe quelle condition
pas à n'importe quel poste en tous les
cas l'entreprise a le droit de
réglementer ce port là donc je vous
renvoie à ces documents
l'information ce sera le meilleur moyen
de faire en sorte que les grands
principes puissent être respectés dans
la vraie vie celle de chacun de nos
concitoyens
merci madame ma taille je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre j'entends bien
votre souhait de développer
l'information j avais même ajouté
l'information alors vous avez fait
référence comme beaucoup d'entre nous à
l'observatoire de la laïcité qui estime
du reste comme le conseil économique
social et environnemental que le cadre
juridique actuel doit permettre de
régler l'ensemble des situations
existantes pour autant
certaines des orientations de cet
observatoire sont contestés par certains
de ses membres et et on voit bien que ce
cadre suffit bien difficilement à
répondre à des situations de la vie de
tous les jours donc les faits que j'ai
mentionnés comme la récente assignation
de charlie hebdo pour délit de blasphème
ou le contexte des décisions judiciaires
dans l'affairé baby loup sont de nature
à inquiéter a donné une interprétation
erronée voir un détournement du principe
de laïcité alors les tentatives de
légiférer ont été trop souvent vouées à
l'échec
et elles ont de ce fait fait le jeu des
adversaires de la république
il n'en reste pas moins je crois que
notre pays tout entier au delà de son
école a besoin pour garantir la liberté
de conscience de tous dans toutes les
situations d'un cadre législatif clair
permettant d'éviter les atermoiements en
matière de laïcité je vous remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur andré
reichardt pour le mouvement groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président nos
ministres ont rappelé la ministre mes
chers collègues le 29 janvier dernier
une proposition de loi a été déposée à
l'assemblée nationale par le député jean
jacques candelier
elle vise à étendre la loi de séparation
des églises et de l'état du 9 décembre
2005 miss 1905 pardon sur l'ensemble du
territoire national et donc à abroger
notamment le droit local tu des cultes
en vigueur en alsace-moselle or celui-ci
institut pour les cultes concordataire
des statuts juridiques particuliers avec
des droits et des obligations pour ces
cultes et pour l'état il garantit dans
le respect de la neutralité religieuse
de l'état une pleine liberté à tous les
cultes et permet de prendre en compte
les besoins de tous ces cultes il assure
une complète séparation de l'état et de
l'église
il permet des relations de confiance et
de collaboration entre l'état et les
cultes et de bonne entente entre les
cultes le droit local des cultes a
traversé toutes les épreuves de
l'histoire de 1870 à nos jours
la seule période où il a été supprimée a
été pendant l'annexion de fait des trois
départements de l'est par l'allemagne
nazie
l' ordonnance de 1944 portant
rétablissement de l'égalité républicaine
et les constituants de 1946 et 1958
assurant le maintien de ce droit
particulier auquel les populations
locales sont très attachés le conseil
constitutionnel dans une décision du 21
février 2013 a d'ailleurs jugé que le
droit local et culte était conforme à la
constitution et 1958 nous alsaciens et
mosellans nous considérons que l'alsace
moselle est tout aussi laïques que les
autres départements français
même si la mise en oeuvre de ce principe
qu'on est chez nous des modalités
original ce droit local a montré sa
souplesse dans la période récente
en contribuant à une bonne intégration
de nos compatriotes de confession
musulmane
grâce à la possibilité pour les
collectivités territoriales de soutenir
financièrement la contribution la
construction pardon de lieux de culte et
de créer même des cimetière
confessionnel musulman d'alors monsieur
le ministre
pouvez vous me confirmer que votre
gouvernement comme les précédents est
fermement attaché au maintien du droit
local et culte et de manière générale
aux divers aspects de la législation
territoriale applicable en
alsace-moselle je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre merci monsieur
le président monsieur monsieur sénateur
vous avez évoqué ce droit local mosellan
alsacien et je voudrais vous rassurer
pour par rapport à l'inquiétude que vous
avez manifesté le concordat vous l'avez
rappelé est le fruit d'une histoire
tragique celle des territoires alsaciens
et mosellans et comme l'ensemble du
droit local il marque un moment
historique un moment historique
aujourd'hui dans notre république qui
doit être ménagé et respectez vous le
concorde 1 reste au coeur du
particularisme alsaciens et mosellans et
lente l'état n'entend pas le remettre en
cause l'état n'entend pas le remettre en
cause cette position a été confortée
vous évoquez tout à l'heure la vie du la
jurisprudence constitutionnelle
et le conseil constitutionnel a donné
rang constitutionnel au principe de
séparation des églises et de l'état
et c'est important parce que c'est la
première fois que ça pu être dit avec
autant de force et qui a été reconnue
l'a confirmé la conformité à notre
constitution de l' exception historique
d'alsace est 2è de la moselle le
principe de le principe et son exception
territoriales sont donc désormais
pleinement consacré est stable c'était
le voeu du gouvernement conformément aux
engagements que le président de la
république lui même a pris lors de sa
campagne présidentielle
je voudrais rappeler que le concordat
n'abolit absolument pas le principe de
laïcité en alsace et en moselle dans ce
département comme sur l'ensemble du
territoire de la république l'état est
neutre indépendant de toute entreprise
de toute emprise et le libre exercice du
culte et total l'organisation des cultes
est différente
certains cultes bénéficie davantage figé
par l'histoire d'autres d'autres moins
les régions concordataire sont des
régions de tolérance où règne un
dialogue de qualité entre les
représentants des grandes confessions
pratiqués en france et rien ne justifie
aujourd'hui que ces équilibres sont
remis en question
j'espère que vous voilà pleinement
rassuré merci monsieur reichardt
merci madame le ministre pour cette
déclaration tout à fait clair la
proposition de monsieur le député
candelier en effet eu l'heur de choquer
les représentants des religions
concordataires des trois départements de
l'est celle ci ne comprenait pas les
raisons pour lesquelles une proposition
de cet ordre été déposée aujourd'hui
alors même que je les dis nos
départements connaissent une laïcité
apaisée qui se confond sans difficulté
avec les respect de toutes les religions
ils ont souhaité avoir une assurance que
cette initiative individuelle
n'appartenait d'un parlementaire ne
prospérera pas dans la procédure
parlementaire il n'aura pas le soutien
de gouvernement quant à moi
vous me permettrez de de simplement
rappelé que toute modification de la
législation locale a toujours eu pour
principe de se faire en lien étroit avec
les parlementaires des départements
concernés et certainement pas à
l'initiative d'un parlementaire aussi
honorable soit il d'une autre région
appartenant qui plus est à un courant de
pensée qui n'est pas majoritaire chez
nous loin s'en faut
je vous remercie une nouvelle fois de
cette déclaration sans ambiguïté merci
la parole est à madame catherine
génisson pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
je souhaite interroger madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre sur le
sujet très important de la laïcité à
l'école d'une manière générale et plus
particulièrement sur le devenir de
l'expérimentation des abcd de l'égalité
qui je le rappelle ont pour objectif de
transmettre dès le plus jeune âge jeune
âge la culture de l'égalité et du
respect entre les filles et les garçons
et je dis bien entre les filles et les
garçons soyons clairs la laïcité à
l'école garantit l'égalité de traitement
de tous les élèves
elle égale dignité de tous les citoyens
la laïcité refuse toutes les
intolérances elle est le fondement du
respect mutuel et de la fraternité la
laïcité n'est pas une entrave à la
liberté mais au contraire la condition
de sa réalisation
c'est aux enseignants qu'il appartient
de transmettre les valeurs laïques
contenus dans la charte de la laïcité
voulu par vincent peillon ministre de
l'éducation nationale charte affiché
cela a été rappelé dans tous les
établissements scolaires depuis la
dernière rentrée de septembre
c'est aux enseignants qu'il appartient
de transmettre les valeurs de la
république de bâtir de l'égalité de la
liberté de la fraternité
il faut accompagner les élèves lors
devenir de citoyens sans blessé aucune
conscience dans la charte de la laïcité
à l'école il est écrit la laïcité
implique le rejet de toutes les
violences et de toutes les
discriminations garantit l'égalité entre
les filles et les garçons et repose sur
une culture du respect de la
compréhension de l'autre
la laïcité est une valeur positive
d'émancipation et les abcd de l'égalité
en sont une parfaite illustration avec
les expérimentations menées dans dix
académies plus de 600 classes pour
transmettre dès le plus jeune âge la
culture de l'égalité et du respect entre
les filles
les garçons la transmission des valeurs
d'égalité entre les filles et les
garçons les femmes et les hommes
constitue une des missions essentielles
de l'école réaffirmé dans la loi du 8
juillet 2013 de refondation de l'école
de la république et de la charte de la
laïcité les inégalités scolaires et
d'orientation détermine trop souvent
celle que l'on retrouve dans les
carrières professionnelles des hommes et
des femmes
ces expérimentations des abcd de
l'égalité sont donc primordiales et si
elles avaient lieu plus précocément il
ya quelques années provoquant ainsi une
prise de conscience de la société face à
des inégalités fille garçon
hommes-femmes inacceptable peut-être que
les femmes seraient plus nombreuses au
sein même de cet hémicycle
je souhaite donc madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre que vous le fassiez
un point d'étape sur des
expérimentations des abbassides et de
l'égalité expérimentation primordial
pour le faire advenir enfin une égalité
réelle fille garçon fire femmes hommes
pouvez-vous d'ores et déjà nous informer
des premiers résultats des évaluations
des expérimentations et quelles sont les
évolutions à attendre pour la rentrée de
septembre 2014 je vous remercie madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice je n'ai pas revenir sur cette
charte qui a été affiché dans les
établissements scolaires et qui est
fondamentale et vous l'avez redis très
bien dans le cadre de la question que
vous avez posé je veux en venir
directement à ces abcd si vous voulez
bien sur lesquels vous porte supporter
la votre question jédir essentiel
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
que la culture de l'égalité soit
vraiment inscrite dans nos
établissements scolaires
elle fait partie de nos valeurs
républicaines les abaisser dès ce n'est
en aucun cas comme on a pu en faire la
caricature une éducation sexuelle
ça n'est en aucun cas une quelconque
théorie du genre
ce sont de vraies séances et de vraies
séquences de cours normales qui
permettent de faire réfléchir les
enfants à l'égalité et au respect mutuel
je pense que là ce sont des mots forts
et qu'ils vous qu'il nous plaît à
entendre par rapport à tout ce qui a pu
être
guy par ailleurs donc pas de caricature
nous sommes là véritablement pour
permettre d'interroger les enfants sur
leurs représentations à travers des
situations d'apprentissage dans des cols
dans des domaines qu'ils connaissent
mais ils connaissent pas toujours aussi
bien qu'il le faut et qui peut les aider
à mieux entrer dans la vie
professionnelle et dans l'insertion
professionnelle donc aujourd'hui et vous
l'avez dit madame la sénatrice il y à un
ensemble d'expérimentation qui ont été
faites en particulier dans dix académies
volontaire et aujourd'hui ces
expérimentations d'un lieu à une
évaluation qui a été demandé à
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale qui doit remettre ses
conclusions mais des conclusions il faut
quand même juste un peu de temps pour
que nous puissions y parvenir les
retours de terrain aujourd'hui une sur 7
sur les référents égalité ne nous sont
parvenues pleinement les inspecteurs
d'académie directeur académique de
services de l'éducation nationale sont
totalement mobilisées totalement
mobilisé sur les retours d'expérience et
des qu'évidemment il nous serons dans
les mains du ministre de l'éducation
nationale il nous fera savoir je le lui
dirai je le confirmerait mais c'est un
point essentiel mais je crois que nous
avons dit repris des mots essentiels
vous et moi merci madame madame génisson
merci madame la ministre de votre
réponse nous attendrons les conclusions
émanant du ministère de l'éducation
nationale et je vous remercie pour la
clarté la clarification au corps
peut-être encore nécessaire a rapporté
que vous avez apporté comme je l'avais
fait dans ma question sur le sujet de
l'égalité entre les filles et les
garçons tout simplement mais de façon
essentielle terminé avec les séance de
questions cribles thématiques je vais
donc suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h pour l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi relative
à la vous est donc que suivre la séance
de questions cribles des questions
cribles consacré à la
laïcité dans le monde du travail on en
reparle ce soir dans 24heures sénat
présenté par delphine girard
à